yes yes
okay
okay
my
um
[Music]
well good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
it's two o'clock so the inquiry is
resumed
it's the usual announcements a fresh
attendance list i hope is circulating
doing the rounds so can you put your
details on that for me please
and a mobile phone if you've got one
with you please make sure it's switched
off or on silent whilst the inquiry is
sitting
um
before i go any further just to let
people know i did carry out
an extensive accompanied site visit this
morning
we walked the washington road saw
the junctions referred to during the
inquiry also
walked the
boundary of the
appeal site itself and viewed the excuse
me the persicotis road access
in terms of things carried over from
yesterday
what's the updated position please on
the conditions i think i've seen
um
a version emailed to the inspectors case
officer can
so someone
yeah that's that's the latest so
i'm told yes right so
following the discussions yesterday um
amendments that were agreed or
where there wasn't agreement at least
i've got the the views of each side and
that's gone to the inspector's case
officer
good thank you
um and the section 106 agreement there
was something that needed a bit of an
amendment there
sorry so it'll be here by three
you've probably heard that okay right
anything from any of the parties before
i move to hear the closings
just me sir i'm afraid i've had a bit of
a technological issue this morning that
i've um i've just been um telling my
learned friend and uh counsellor foster
about
um could i just request a few minutes
please before we start because um i said
there's been a technological issue in
terms of getting a copy printed out and
sorting it out so
maybe just 20 minutes if we may now or
no i think it would help because it will
help me to have my own in front of me so
i can annotate it as necessary in terms
of responding to the other party's
points well just before i'll do that
i'll adjourn for another 20 minutes and
we'll resume a little bit later then but
just before i do that can i just check
whether any of the interested persons
who spoke on the first day and who
subsequently have put questions to the
appellants
witnesses wanted to make a closing
summary i i've worded it like that
because those who spoke on the first day
and have then taken no further active
part
in the inquiry by questioning witnesses
your position can't have changed so i've
got your statement uh that you gave on
day one and as i've said many times you
can't introduce new evidence uh in
closing submissions so i'm content that
i've got the
the position of those who spoke on day
one and then didn't subsequently speak
further but obviously a few of you did
um
ms wright
mrs taylor eve and
mr gardner so i don't i would only
really want to hear from you if as a
result of that questioning your position
has changed in any way your case has
changed in any way if not then again i'm
in the same position i have the
statements that you gave me
on
tuesday of last week but can i just
check did any i any of you three
want to make any brief closing summary
that's right
no
no no so i might make a comment uh mr
mick vanner he wishes to make his
apologies to you he said he's sorry
about entering the evidence late his
wife has alzheimer's and he got called
away quickly to he couldn't get anybody
to sit with her so he just wanted to
make his apologies to everybody he
wasn't trying it on
thank you for that
mr mr vanner did make um his statement
to me on day one and i've got his
statement so
i understood that he got something
additional that he wanted to add to that
and that's really where i was having to
draw the line oh so he got called away
because he his sitter let him down for
his wife and he would have liked to have
made it originally and that's all he
wanted to say okay right okay
so we will adjourn then it's
205 if we come back
225 is that going to be okay and and
then um mr foster and mrs austin i'll
hear the closing submissions for the
rule 6 party
so i'll adjourn now will resume again at
2 25. thank you
um
well the inquiry is resumed then ladies
and gentlemen
what was that sufficient
good thank you
um
before i ask mr foster
i think i mentioned it in the case
management conference summary no but if
i didn't i'm going to say it now can the
main parties please email copies of your
closing submissions to the inspectors
case officer thank you
so mr foster can i
hear the closing submissions for the
rockford supporters group please
thank you sir
sorry have i got a hard copy of this
thank you are there copies for the other
parties
oh we didn't realize we had to sir i was
just told originally that it was a hard
copy and a
email copy
if we've got a minute we could get a
copy made whatever it's made i mean if
if um if cam sorry
um
if councillor foster wants to
i mean we'll have to break again but if
councillor foster wants to email copy to
mr pycroff we've got a printer in the
room and we'll be able to
organize some printing if that would
assist yes i'm sorry i obviously should
have referred to that before the
adjournment that
it's customary
for copies
for each of the main parties so we can
follow in detail and annotate if need be
i think we can do that email as
suggested okay
so
how long is that going to take i mean it
it seems silly to have another
adjournment if we're only going to be a
few minutes i'm happy to
for us to
just sit quietly if uh if we can do that
i do apologize sir i didn't uh
understand that we had to provide other
copies
well it is perhaps partially my fault mr
foster i could easily have referred to
it earlier so
don't fret yourself about it
do we know this guy's um
let's do it
so
uh
uh
okay
[Applause]
okay i think we're
about ready to go there mr foster
right thank you sir i would just say um
i've never done anything like this
before so i hope this structure is okay
thank you
i'd like to first comment on the inquiry
process if i may
um while sir you've conducted the
inquiry absolutely fairly and in line
with the rules as we understand them
i have to say it seems weighted against
the rule six party and to an extent
against the planning authority
firstly the highways authority who
recommended approval
and that was the key reason behind the
approval was the recommendation of the
highways authority
they don't appear here and therefore
could not be cross-examined
and i think as i say i recognize that
we've gone in line with process but that
doesn't seem an appropriate
point
secondly
on the 24th of january more than five
weeks after the original objective
the highway consultant for rochford
district council signed a statement of
common ground which became a major
oft quoted
part of the appellant's case
there were clear flaws
but we could not cross-examine because
we were apparently on the same side as
the highways consultant
and as i understand it the council is
also representing rockford district
council were not even aware that that
statement of common ground had been
signed until they arrived here on the
tuesday morning
and i hope those comments are helpful
maybe for future inquiries
so now to address and summarize the
issues
the single ground for rejection had been
that the development committee
considered the highway impact to be
severe
despite office officers recommending
approval
on the inquiry opening day the right
honourable mark francois mp reported on
his meeting
with essex county council highways
officers on the 5th of december 2020.
sorry
isaac county council highways officers
rocha district councillors and planning
officers on the 5th february 5th of
november 2020
essex highways officers conceded at the
meeting that some junctions were already
and i put it in quotes because
mr francois said that's what they said
some junctions were already swamped
they also stated
that they could only reject the
application if the traffic effect was
deemed severe
however since the nppf was not defined
has not defined severe
essex county council stated that the
judgment was entirely subjective and i
put that in quotes because that's what
mr francois said they said
which made it difficult to object to the
application
as part of our evidence we produced a
highway map supported by descriptions of
junction traffic quoted from the ringway
jacobs essex county council rochford
local plan highways baseline technical
note dated 25th of october 2017. so
though it's sort of recognized as a
ringway jacobs note
it was done on behalf of essex county
council highways
it stated that all the junctions on our
map
and the and berlin junction which was
below the level of the map were
congested or highly congested
however
interestingly ringway jacobs did
in their technical baseline note have a
table which describes the measure of
congestion
from low through to severe
and that was page 46 table 4.1 of the
report that we produced
now
a reminder it's a ringway jacobs report
but that is on behalf of essex county
council so that was in effect essex
county highways
definition of severe
we've seen evidence that the assessment
of traffic impact should consider
cumulative impact of developments to
repeat the statement from mr francois
the comments from essex highways
that the definition of what constitutes
a severe effect was entirely subjective
this proves and i repeat proves
that the highways authority did not and
i repeat not
test even the individual
let alone cumulative predict predicted
traffic impact against its own
definition of severe
per the ringway jacobs table described
earlier
within the junction of with sorry within
the description of junctions i would em
emphasize one the hall road action road
west street junction
the runway jacobs report page 45
describes this and other roundabouts
having traffic safety and congestion
issues
it highlights in page 49
in relation to this roundabout high
levels of congestion are observed for
all three approaches to the ashland road
hall road west street roundabout
it's been accepted and stated by all
parties in evidence here that no changes
can be made to this roundabout
it's worth reminding ourselves of the
brandon lewis house of commons response
to a written question attachment 14 in
our original evidence
and i quote
it's for the local planning authority in
considering planning applications
or the planning inspector in considering
planning appeals
to consider whether improvements can be
undertaken within the transport network
that cost effectively limit the
significant impact of the development on
traffic levels
and determine whether the residual
cumulative impacts of the development
are severe end of quote
as i said it's clear from all statements
of all parties that no improvements can
be made to this junction
indeed in evidence we submitted
photographs which demonstrated the chaos
there
so
we have a junction which cannot be
improved
we have no evidence
that the local planning authority ever
tested the cumulative impact of
development development against any
definition of severe
but relied completely on the entirely
subjective conclusion of the highways
authority
it's clear
on this factor alone that the appeal
should be rejected
however
no doubt the appellant as we have heard
earlier will argue
earlier in the week
we'll argue that ser eight having been
included in the local development
framework course strategy would require
that the appeal should be approved
in the course strategy it clearly states
the requirement for local highway
capacity
and
infrastructure improvements
as we've argued and evidence the tweaks
to many roundabouts are insignificant
and there is no increase in highway
capacity
we know that not every hour of every day
is rammed solid
but we have shown that for many hours on
most days ashland road and key junctions
are severely congested
often it's intolerable
in our evidence we submitted many
pictures including the horror junction
which support our argument
it would be remiss not to mention
additional issues
first of all air quality
the appellants expert witness agreed
that there is no automatic air quality
monitoring in the area
and no measure of air quality near the
schools the four schools and days
nursery in ashland road
he also agreed that the likely pollution
impact of construction traffic and
current and future domestic gas heating
systems had not been assessed
when asked to confirm that school
children would be breathing polluted air
his reaction was
everybody does
well that's okay then isn't it
tell that to the family of the young
girl in south london whose death was
attributed by the coroner to pollution
caused by traffic
a further point to be made is that the
ardent traffic assessment page 47 4.2 d
highlights from the nppr
the environment impacts of traffic and
transport infrastructure should provide
net gains so i repeat
the impacts of traffic and transport
infrastructure should provide net gains
on the environment
in environmental quality sorry
how can there possibly be environmental
gains if we do not even measure air
quality near schools how do we know what
we're gaining against
whilst arguing that the traffic impact
would not be severe the appellant
offered the view
that drivers would take alternative
routes to avoid congestion
as per the previously mentioned evidence
all junctions are congested
so take a congested route to avoid
congestion doesn't seem to make a lot of
sense
i was going to make a comment about the
um
traffic
sorry travel
arrangements but um it's not in the
typed version so i suppose i should not
say that
you can say it if if it's part of your
closing yes by all means thank you say
it slowly and i'll make sure i take down
what you say
um
it was also suggested talking about
other other traffic related issues and
the travel plan
is also suggested by ardence that
residents would be encouraged
to take alternative routes by providing
now i heard earlier in the week and last
week talked about several months worth
of free
bus tickets
but what it actually said in the argent
report was they'd be provided six
scratch cards for three day
travel it generated a laugh but i think
it's laughable to suggest that six
scratch cards for free bus travel is
going to change people's travel habits
there was another comment mentioned in
in
evidence by the appellant about online
shopping
about the suggestion that online
shopping will reduce traffic and i think
that's unproven
online shopping equals home deliveries
including drop sites which often cause
traffic jams as we as we witness
regularly on ashton road and also
actually there are drop boxes as we saw
the jet garage and
golden cross where people have to
collect their parcels that have been
dropped off so that actually is travel
journeys as well
the appellant also argued that the
housing delivery trajectory to 2025
would leave a housing shortfall
as i said in evidence the 2021 housing
delivery test per the planning policy
and communities government website
identified rochford as having over
delivered in the period 2018 through
2021
further additional opportunities have
also been adopted which we believe would
address the unlikely shortfall the
unlikely shortfall
the appellant argued also that there is
a shortfall in the five-year land supply
from
2025. the housing need for that period
has not yet been established for that
planned period
and is the subject of ongoing discussion
with the housing minister
for that reason the development of the
new local plan has paused that the
background work is going on to analyze
the almost 200 sites which have been
offered in the call for sites
so it's presumptive to on the behalf of
the appellant to state that there is a
shortfall of land
to argue that rochefort district council
will fail on housing delivery and land
supply is conjecture and is not a reason
to approve the
appeal
that said
i'll refer to the appeal and i won't
read all the digits out it's in there
for you to uh
to access if you wish in random kent
which we discussed earlier in the week
in rejecting that appeal the inspector
noted that the traffic impact would be
severe
and though there would be a significant
shortfall in housing land supply that of
itself was not a reason to approve
referring to the local plan as here in
rochford he stated that in lights of its
early stage no weight is afforded to it
i.e the
land supply
i just offer that as
as a precedent for the position i've
just described in relation to rochford
so in summary
we believe the traffic impact of the
proposed development development
with an average of two garages and over
a thousand vehicles will be severe
neither the highway nor planning
authority have tested the predicted
impact of this
or cumulative developments against any
definition of
severe the arcadey model which gave
unliked results which we discussed about
uh last week i think it was
um
the roles results which didn't suit the
uh applicant
were suggested to be dismissed
so the modeling
the the algorithms and the systems used
if they don't give the right results
ignore them
traffic modelling considered junctions
but not flows between or after junction
so for example the amberlynn roundabout
changes cannot help highway flow along
sutton road and again if if you live in
this area and travel those areas
relatively frequently you know that when
you turn left
at the and berlin into sutton road it
particularly in the morning is backed up
from almost from south end
the requirement for improvement of
highway capacity
a key requirement of ser 8
is not met by the proposed development
the suggestion that traffic congestion
can be avoided by alternative routes is
not viable
the likely impact of proposed mode
change slash travel plan plans was not
evidence
you may recall i asked for particular
evidence in
comparison with other areas like
rochford
the suggestions of an inadequate housing
delivery trajectory
is not supported by fact
the implied shortfall of land supply is
fanciful and not reason for approving an
appeal
and i mentioned the kent precedent for
that
so in the opinion of the rockford
supporters group which represents the
residents of the area in which we live
we believe the appeal should be clearly
rejected
thank you
okay thank you mr foster and
miss
mrs austin would you like to
be your part of the
brochures supporters groups closing
submissions please
i think
okay
when you are
sir when i first gave my speech at the
opening of this public inquiry i said
that it was all too easy to get caught
up in the facts and figures the
arguments and counter-arguments and the
david versus goliath nature of this case
after hearing everything that has been
said over the last week i stand by that
statement the quantity of statistics and
data and the arguments for and against
have been nothing short of bamboozling
you have heard from us the rochester
supporters group that we are absolutely
convinced this development will bring
traffic that the roads cannot handle
that this development will bring risk of
injury or worse to the children of holt
farm infant and junior schools
and this development will bring misery
to every single one of us who lives in
and around rochford
you also heard that even though the
planning office has accepted the
application was nppf compliant
it was ultimately refused by councillors
as it was clear that sufficient due
diligence had not diligence had not been
undertaken by the council's officers
and that very obviously this development
wasn't and still isn't right for
rochford
this decision made clear and perhaps
even set a precedent
that just because something can be
viewed as policy compliant it isn't
necessarily right and appropriate
after hearing from us you heard from the
appellant
you heard from their expensively
assembled team that traffic congestion
won't be an issue and children will be
fine crowded on a small island in the
middle of a road trying not to get run
over on the way to school
the developer even managed to get a last
minute addition to one of their reports
from the very much noted but elusive mr
flexman
to convince you that if rdc's transport
consultant doesn't object then why
should you
i think it is noteworthy that this
seemingly supportive comment was
introduced out of the blue
it came unexpectedly and at the very
last minute to me that reeks of a
desperate attempt to find something to
hook their argument on and i find mr
flexman's actions questionable to say
the least
so i think it's fair to say that both
sides have opposite views one side
confidently says
this will cause misery and risk for the
town
and the other side less convincingly
says no he'll be okay
so back we must go to the facts and
figures for something to sway the
decision one way or the other with
sufficient certainty that everyone can
be confident that even if they don't
like the decision it is a fair one
and it is here that it becomes clear why
i referred to david versus goliath
goliath brought in analysts with their
modeling statistics who tried to present
their findings as irrefutable
but i don't believe they achieved that
we all know the results of modeling are
directly related to a data set used we
all know the results can be manipulated
by the modelling software and we all
know that ultimately modeling gives
whichever result the person paying for
it wants
i won't labor the part point but let's
be honest it wasn't exactly compelling
was it
and let's not forget those last minute
comments attributed to mr flexman in a
last-ditch effort to drive home their
message and yes that pun was intended
their attempt to drive home the point
was as torturous as our attempts to
drive to and from work and school
will be if this development is approved
but goliath didn't stop there did they
no they brought him misread qc
a lady who i have in awe of
and i am
she argued brilliantly for her client
and has demonstrated a particular skill
in her questioning of everybody
throughout this inquiry
i have no doubt at all that if i could
have afforded to pay for her to be on
our side this case would already be
closed with a resounding rejection of
the appeal ringing loudly for rochford
to celebrate
but please allow me to unpick my
comments a little for whilst my
compliment about our learning friend is
genuine i must be clear with you
the skill in questioning i referred to
is her formulation of a leading question
this is a common skill of barristers and
interviewers and was very well executed
here
on every possible occasion she purposely
formulated the question to lead the
respondent to the answer she needed
trapping them so even if it wasn't the
answer they wanted to give it was the
only one they could
it's an old interviewing trick cleverly
played but a trick nevertheless
in the same way that tv deres brown she
uses mind tricks and manipulation to
lead his audience to subtly reveal the
clues he needs so he can pretend to read
their minds so do does a qc use tricks
to get the answers they need to support
their argument
so as you reflect on the answers people
gave under her questioning please bear
in mind that they were trapped into that
answer and then not allowed by her to
give the context required to explain
their answer
as with the modeling it's not exactly
compelling is it
albert einstein once said if you can't
explain it simply you don't understand
it well enough
and i think this is an interesting quote
to consider
we all heard the complex statistics that
the appellant to believe their
application should be approved and i'm
confident it is not just me phil's
complex is a suitable adjective
and that makes me wonder
could the appellant have made their
argument simpler to ease everyone's
understanding of the facts
yes without a doubt they could so why
didn't they i would wager that they rely
on a complex argument filled with
mountains of statistics precisely so
that it remains confusing
if they had explained their argument
more simply if they had helped everyone
understand the intricacies of the the
direct impact of this development it
would be all too easy for everyone to
see just how bad this development will
be for rochford
the appellate appellate didn't want to
risk us all understanding well enough so
they tried not to explain it simply
enough
i don't believe they achieve that either
neither do i believe
have any of their arguments been
sufficiently convincing that the sir
eight should join the 80 of developer
applications that have been victorious
at appeal stage
is a shocking statistic 80 percent of
appeals submitted by
developers are one
and why do they win
because all those goliaths can throw
enough money to do exactly what law
developments are trying to do here
hide the overwhelmingly negative impact
their development would bring behind the
statistics and modeling they paid for
and an expensive barrister who can tie
people in knots and get get ticks in
just about enough boxes to make it hard
to say no and i think significant weight
should be given to that
so there we have it sir our david versus
their goliath
our evidence proving the roads cannot
support the additional traffic that they
will create
versus their modelling that at best
suggest it might potentially not be a
total catastrophe
our straightforward and honest
declarations of the evidence we have
collated versus their use of age-old
interviewing
techniques to lead respondents
irreversibly and unavoidably into giving
specific answers
our evidence belief that this
development will do more harm for
rochford than good versus their belief
that throwing money to tick the
necessary boxes at the appeal is all
that matters as they don't have to live
with the negative consequences
our knowledge of the local area versus
their well lack of it
sir should i say a massive decision such
as this be decided on a developer doing
just about enough to tick the boxes no
it's not right is it
should the developer get their way just
because they can throw more money at
this than those who are against them no
it's not right is it
should this development be approved
no it's not right is it
profit should never come before people
sadly it appears in most cases that they
do
thank you
okay thank you very much
thank you
so mr parkinson can i hear the closing
submissions for the
council please
so it's just been circulated
thank you sir as i said in opening the
council's case is simple but it's
fundamental the appeal scheme would have
an unacceptable impact on the road
network and the council's positions
unchanged at the end of the evidence
this is a development that is the
planning committee correctly identified
would have a severe residual cumulative
impact on the local highway network
contrary to paragraph 111 of the mppf
and this closing is simply a summary of
the council's evidence and case which is
set out in full in its evidence to the
inquiry
so i'll start off with the existing
conditions
before considering whether or not the
impacts of the development is severe
it's essential to understand the nature
of the local highway network
that's because the severity of an impact
on the highway network depends on the
sensitivity to change the area where it
occurs
this development will impact the highway
network in a particularly sensitive
location
ashington road is a key strategic route
connecting washington to rochford and on
a wider level it's classified as
priority one road by essex county
council
that means that it's one of the key
traffic arteries in which for districts
as a whole and is an important
inter-urban route
the road is particularly important for
north-south trips across the district
and the hall road junction junction 4
is a key junction on the ashington road
and in rochford town center the most
direct route for anyone driving to and
from ashington hockley south end and
rochford will take you through the hall
road junction
clearly any potential changes to the
operation of the highway network in this
location needs to be considered very
carefully indeed
that's particularly the case because
during the am and pm peaks at the very
least the ashington road and whole road
roundabout is already congested
as long ago as december 2011 this was
recognized in the core strategy which
states that action should be taken to
improve traffic flows and reduce
congestion on the ashton road
mr blair rightly accepted that this was
a clear recognition in the development
plan that congestion on ashton road
needed to be reduced
unfortunately the situation has not
improved in the last 10 years
the appellant's own transport assessment
addendum for this application states
that the local highway network is
congested and this has also been
recognised by the council in its most
recent consultation document for the
emerging local plan which states that
the aston road is known to have
congestion issues
the appellant has calculated that the
hour in the morning when the total flow
through the hall road junction is
greatest is between 7 15 and 8 15 a.m
plainly it will be necessary to reach a
view about the level of existing
congestion
whilst the appellant's q surveys carried
out on a single day 24th march 2019 have
not been challenged by the council
reaching a judgment on the existing
level of congestion requires
consideration of more than just queue
lengths
councilor reeves explained his
experience of congestion during the amp
hour and you sir have heard many
accounts from residents which as mr
blair accepted must be given weight
residents provide a real-world
on-the-ground experience that models
can't reproduce
and more weight should be given to their
experiences than those of mr blair who
only visited the site in person on two
days 9th and 10th december 2021 and
experience the amp can only won on the
10th of september 2021 and travel
through the whole road junction on only
a few occasions within that peak period
further as mr blair accepted washington
road and the hall road junction is busy
in periods outside of the amp cow for
example during the school run period
again that cannot be ignored
the baseline position in 2029 is even
more stark
even without the development the the
that should say junction the junction is
undoubtedly congested
for example existing queues now on the
ashton road arm of the hall road
roundabout are modeled to be about 17
passenger car units pcus
that will go up to 33 pcus without the
development over a 90 increase
the average delay in 2029 even without
the development would be 140 seconds per
pcu
in those circumstances even a small
increase in queuing and delay can give
rise to a severe residual cumulative
impact and in this respect it's
important to know that essex county
council as local highway authority
concluded that the development would be
acceptable on the basis that it would
result in nil detriment compared to that
baseline position
so what do the models results show in
2029
the model results in mr blair's evidence
show the position in 2029 with the
development on the appellant's own
figures
throughout the inquiry the appellant has
asked the council to provide its own
evidence that the impact will be severe
however there's no obligation on the
council to produce its own separate
modeled results
it's perfectly legitimate for the
council to point to the appellant's own
results as demonstrating a severe
residual cumulative impact
those results speak for themselves
without the need for further evidence
the focus of the council's case
is on the impacts on the key hall road
roundabout in the am peak
this focus on the peak period is
perfectly normal when assessing junction
capacity it's that period when demand at
the junctions is highest and when the
most people are likely to be affected by
the changes to the road network
blair has produced modelled results for
the period 7 15 to 8 15 am
these provide the ratio of flow to
capacity for the junction and each of
his arms over the peak hour and in 15
minute time segments
the headline figure is that in 2029 with
the development the junction
junction would be 15 over capacity 9
more than it would be in the baseline
position without the development
in other words the junction is not able
to let the traffic demand through and
that manifests itself in cues and delay
as mr blair accepted on all arms of the
junction there is a material increase in
delay and queuing with the development
in 2029 compared to without the
development
breaking that down in all of the 15
minute time segments on the ashenton
road on there was a material increase in
delay compared to the baseline position
in 2029 and in all of the 15 minute time
segments on the ashiton road arm there
was an increase in queuing compared to
the baseline position in 2029
taking all of the time segments and all
of the arms there's an overall increase
in delay across the junction as a whole
from 77 seconds to 213 seconds per pcu
the maximum queue on the ashton road
across the hour increases from 33 pcus
to 118 pcus
the level of service of the ashton road
arm is f
that records how the junction is working
and as mr blair explained means that
there's a low level of service
there is no lower score
and that's on mr blair's new figures
in his proof of evidence mr blair made
three main changes to the modelling in
the original transport assessment and
transport assessment addendum
revisions of the temporary growth rates
vehicular trip generation rates and the
validating of junction models to correct
a mistake relating to the geometry of
the junctions
however on both traffic generation and
growth mr blair accepted that the
approach taken by ace was not an
unreasonable approach that it led to a
robust assessment
and that and this is a quote the
approach they adopted was appropriate
for what they were doing which was
providing a robust assessment
the changes that mr blair has made
they're not ultimately judgment calls
whilst mr blair considers that his
inputs are more accurate he does not go
as far as to say that the ace tempora
and trip rates fall outside of a
reasonable range of judgment
so when looking at the modelling
outcomes you sir can bear in mind that
the modelling produced with the ace
tempera and trip rates
um
would not be i think falls should be
taken out there
so the modelling produced with the ac
temper and trip rates would not be an
unreasonable prediction of what will
happen at the hallway junction junction
4.
the effect of that is delay of 524
seconds per pcu on the ashton road arm
of the junction
up from 451 seconds on mr blair's
figures and maximum queues of 137 pcus
up from 118 on mr blair's figures
it was suggested to councillor eves in
cross-examination that his concern
related only to the final 15-minute
period of the peak hour
and the development only added 25
additional vehicles to the junction
compared to the baseline period
this approach is entirely wrong and
misunderstands
how and why the cues and delay in the
final 15 minute period are so long
the starting point is that over the peak
hour the development results in
an additional 103 vehicles trying to get
through the junction
those additional vehicles are fairly
evenly spread across the peak hour we've
on average 26 additional vehicles from
the development every 15 minutes
compared to the baseline position in
2029
the queues experienced in the final 15
minutes are a result of the extra 103
vehicles from the development across the
hour
at the beginning of the final 15 minute
period there is already a queue at the
junction of 89.6 pcus and that's because
the junction is already overloaded and
above capacity before the final 25
vehicles from the development arrive at
8
a.m the junction is overloaded to this
extent and the queues are this long
because of the additional 78 vehicles
from the development which add to the
demand between 7 15 and 8 am
the additional 25 vehicles from the
development that arrive in the final 25
minutes extend an existing queue that is
the size it is because of the additional
development traffic in the preceding 45
minutes
mr blair accepted the queues and not
just the product that springs up at at
8am
and that the queues are growing because
of what happens from 7 15
which includes the additional 103 not 25
pcus seeking to go through the junction
because of the development
in simple terms and as mr blair accepted
the situation in the final 15 minutes is
a product of what's happened in the
preceding 45 minutes it's therefore
entirely simplistic and wrong to say
that the council's case boils down to an
additional 25 additional vehicles in the
final 15 minute period
to get to nil detriment the mr blair and
ecc said would occur with the
development
26 vehicles need to be removed in every
single quarter not just the final
quarter of an hour
further because the cues and delay are
so long at the end of the hour the
junction will not immediately revert
back to the position it was in before
the start of the peak hour as mr blair
accepted cues and delays will step back
down
finally and significantly the cues that
result from the development word on the
modeled results stretch back beyond the
dailies road roundabout junction 3.
distance between junctions 3 and 4 is
410 meters that's the equivalent of just
over 71 pcus
the model q of 118 pcu in the period 8
am to 8 15 will extend back from
junction 4 to a distance of 678 meters
well beyond daily's road
the queue in the period 745 to 8am would
be
89.6 pcu long equivalent to
515.2 meters this would also block back
to junction 3.
as such based on the modeled results mr
blair accepted that for half the morning
picara period
cues from junction 4 would extend back
beyond junction 3 and southbound traffic
down washington road would not be able
to exit the roundabout and head straight
ahead towards the hall road roundabout
and all of the above is on the basis of
a queue with hardly any gaps between
vehicles
mr blair considered the queue would be a
slow moving queue but accepted that this
would result in larger gaps between
vehicles
taking this into account interaction
between the junctions will occur before
the queue reaches 71 pcus
and the length of the maximum q in the
peak area period would be over 700
meters
since arcade models junctions in
isolation it does not take account of
blocking back or interactions between
junctions and as a result the effects of
queues blocking back is that the
capacity of the junction is reduced
since the model assumes a free-flowing
junction
plainly therefore the modeled results
show a severe residual cumulative impact
whether a residual cumulative impact is
severe under paragraph 111 of the mppf
as a matter of judgment
the mppf does not quantify what level of
impact would fall within the realm of
severe
and nor does the mppf or planning
practice guidance set out what factors
need to be taken into account
but it's common ground that the factors
which are relevant in assessing whether
there's a clear severe impact include
queue lengths delay
impact on overall journey times the
number of road users affected by any
impacts
and the availability of alternative
routes to avoid the congestion caused
and dealing with those now on the
appellant's own figures in the am peak
in 2029 without the development the
average delay on the ashington road
approach will be 140 seconds per pcu and
the maximum queue would be 33 if equals
the residual effect of the development
would be to increase this delay to 451
seconds with a maximum queue of 118 pcus
this would amount to an increasing delay
on this key approach by over two
a hundred percent from
2.5 to 7.5 minutes and to increase the
average maximum q by 85 pcus
as a key strategic north-south route
those figures during the amp hour would
affect a large number of road users both
on the local highway network but also
those drivers from outside the immediate
era
overall journey times will increase both
for those on shorter journeys within
watford and also those on longer routes
from outside the immediate era area
there would also be blocking back of
queues across junctions affecting the
ability not only of the whole road
roundabout to deal with demand but also
that'll junction free
as mr blair accepted there would be no
blocking back
um so that i should add in there in
which there should be no
there would be no blocking back without
the development so we just add in the
words without the development
this is a key change between the
baseline position in 2029
and that with the development
based on the modeled results there can
be no doubt that the residual cumulative
impact on the local highway network
would be severe
so i turn next to whether anything can
be done to prevent the modelled severe
residual cumulative impact
um the distance between junctions three
and four is 410 meters that's the
equivalent of just over 71 pcus
therefore to avoid blocking back almost
47 pcus which are modeled to travel
through the whole road junction in the
am peak need to be removed from the
network in that location
of course that's a robust assessment
since it proceeds on the basis of a
largely stationary queue with limited
gaps between the vehicles if the queue
is a slow moving queue more than 47 pcus
would need to be removed to avoid the
interaction between junctions three and
four
before turning to the factors relied on
by mr blair it's important to note that
no physical mitigation is proposed in
the hall road junction
nor is there a long-term scheme for
physical improvements to the junction
the appellant accepts the highway works
at the whole road junction cannot be
easily undertaken
the railway bridge has restrictions on
its height and width and washington road
and west street have restricted widths
due to the properties on the stream on
either side
in simple terms usa must proceed on the
basis that capacity at the hallway
junction
will not be increased for an engineered
solution before 2029.
mr blair relied on eight factors which
he said would avoid the severe effects
shown by the model and there as follows
travel plan alternative routes
alternative times peak spreading trip
internalization working from home
temporal approach sustainable
enhancements and the study area and i'll
deal with each of these in turn so doing
first with the travel plan
mr blair's reliance on the travel plan
to reduce demand
during the hall road junction during the
peak hour ignored the fundamental floor
his traffic flows through the junction
already took into account a traffic plan
reduction adding one on top to further
reduce the flows to avoid the severe
impacts of the queue stretching from
ashington road back through and past the
daily road junction is clearly double
counting
the starting point is that the traffic
flows in the original ta signed off by
ecc were mostly derived um mostly
derived the development trip generation
from trix science that did not include a
travel plan mr blair then tweaked this
in evidence in chief mr blair went
through the changes which were
characterized in broad terms as minor
adjustments to bring the trick site
selected more in line with the
locational characteristics on the
development side
however mr blade did not reveal a key
adjustment made unlike the original ta
as he accepted in cross-examination the
traffic generation in his revised
modeling is based on sites which were
approved with a travel plan in place
therefore the extreme cues and delays on
ashton road that mr blair is predicting
with the development in 2029 is based on
development flows that already have been
reduced to take into account the effects
of a travel plan
it's entirely inappropriate to further
reduce those flows to take into account
something which is already reflected in
the modelling
mr blair accepted that there's an
element of travel plan in the base flows
and that user had to take that into
account
for this reason alone no weight can be
given to the potential for the travel
plan to reduce flows through the whole
road junction in the am peak
in any event the travel plan seeks 10
reduction in the number of two-way peak
uh period vehicular trips
that's a target not a binding commitment
and the quantum of reduction is
therefore unknown
but even if the travel plan target is
reached only 10 cars would be removed
from the whole road junction across the
peak hour
turning next to alternative routes
this was an after fort that was
developed by the appellant at the
inquiry there can be no excuse for this
councillor eaves challenged the ability
to take alternative routes in his
original proof
as mr blair accepted and neither the ta
the transport assessment addendum or his
proof did he set out what the
alternative routes were that could be
taken to avoid congestion at hall road
indeed when essex county council signed
off on the scheme in his consultation
response it did not rely on the
potential for alternative routes
nor were any potential alternative
routes but to councilor eaves when he
was challenged on his evidence
for the first time in evidence in chief
mr blair relied on the potential for
cars to turn left at the dalias road
roundabout and take a crosstown route
down daley's road eventually joining up
with the ambulan roundabouts
on the basis that some people already
turn left down dailies road mr blair
simply assumed that additional cars
currently modelled to travel through the
hall road roundabout could take the same
route
however that assumes that those people
already turning left at daley's road are
doing so to avoid hall road and that
more people could do so it ignores the
fact that people may be turning left
because their destination is down
daley's road such as councillor shaw who
takes that route already not to avoid
hall road but to travel to her food bank
it also assumes that additional people
will be willing and able to take that
route over and above what's already
modelled there's simply no evidential
basis for this
the appellants carried out no survey of
whether people would be willing or able
to take alternative routes the only
survey that we have produced by helen
wright shows that only 1.92 of
respondents who travel in the period 7
to 9 30 a.m did not already change their
existing route
and did not already change their
existing route could do in the future
that's a factor that should be given
either no or very limited weight and
there's simply no evidential support for
it
next alternative times and peak
spreading
again there's an evidential vacuum here
despite councillor eve's querying the
ability of peak spreading
clearly the ability to peak spread to
take journeys at different times is
limited by a number of constraints
as mr blair accepted there are some
journeys that have to occur at a
specific time for example the school run
peak but also some journeys to work
further the appellant must point to
additional peak spreading if people are
already adjusting their journey time
then this is reflected in the existing
network flows on the modeling
the appellate relies on the survey
carried out by helen wright that defines
rush hour at 7 00 to 9 30 a.m
obviously that's a much longer period
than the am peak modeled by the
appellant and much longer than the half
and half an hour in that peak that
results in blocking back across the
daily road junction
only 10 percent of people in the survey
so that they could change their time of
travel but we do not know what
proportion of those people are traveling
between 7 45 a.m and 8 15 a.m
there's no benefit to the appellate
whatsoever if people currently traveling
between 7 and 7 45 am could adjust their
journey time and travel through the
whole road junction between 7 45 and 8
15 am because that's the period when
excessive queuing already occurs and
when vehicles need to be taken off the
road
mr blair accepted that he never relied
on a survey like this from a third party
with the response rate received to this
survey asking questions about a peak
period that's different from the model
peak at an inquiry before
the reasons why are obvious
the appellant's reliance on ms wright's
survey should be given no weight and
since this is the only positive evidence
that the dependent relies on so should
the appellant's reliance on this factor
to avoid the catastrophic cueing that
would otherwise occur
turning next to trip internalization
mr blair's point is that this site is
close to existing schools and therefore
vehicular trips which are assumed to be
for education will be internalized and
will manifest as journeys on foot or
other non-car modes
however mr blair did not know whether
the five trick sites upon which he
derived his trip rates were within
walking distance of a primary in
secondary school
without knowing that no real weight can
be placed on this factor
since if they were the trip rates upon
which mr blair's model flows were based
would already take into account the fact
that some journeys to school were being
walked
next working from home
again this is highly speculative and
without evidential support yes more
people are currently working from home
however the last couple of years have
been highly unusual to say the least
what we're interested in is the position
in 2029 in seven years time
we simply do not know whether or not
people will be working from home to a
similar extent at this point and whether
there will be an increase from the
position in 2019 when the existing base
flows were calculated as mr blair
originally said in his proof the quantum
reduction that this will result in is
unknown
um
next temporary approach mr blair's point
here is that temporo does not take into
account the highway improvements that
might be delivered by allocated sites
however is he accepted this approach
is completely standard and really does
not
so completely standard is a quote from
mr blair and then carrying on in my
language it really does not help the
appellant because as mr blair accepted
if highway improvements to the whole
road roundabouts are difficult these
other sites may well not deliver any
improvements to the junction
this point should be disregarded it's
the appellant scraping the barrel to
find reasons to disregard its own
modelling
next sustainable transport
a large part of the 10 reduction in
trips caused by the travel plan comes
from the sustainable transport
contribution delivered by the
development
therefore the benefits from sustainable
transport in terms of development trips
has already been taken into account in
mr blair's first factor which i've
addressed above
what the appellate must demonstrate is
that the sustainable transport
improvements will result in a sufficient
reduction in non-development trips to
avoid the long queues and delays
predicted on the ashland road
and there simply is not enough evidence
to do so
there's no assessment or way of
quantifying the extent to which others
will use the additional bus services
whilst the council has accepted that the
contribution meets the seal tests on the
basis that it assists in providing
sustainable means of travel that does
not mean that the residual cumulative
impact of the development is not severe
as mr blair accepted that even if
appropriate opportunities to promote
sustainable transport modes have been
taken up
in accordance with paragraph 110a of the
mppf
if the residual cumulative impact of the
development is still severe
it will fail to comply with a paragraph
111 of the mppf
and then finally study area
mr blair's points that the model does
not take into account the fact that
people may take um
trips to within the town centre
however as he accepted this hasn't been
modeled and it would only apply to trips
from within the development and
therefore any discount from that in the
am peak would be as a percentage of 303
additional vehicles from the development
in addition with the appendage travel
plan some of these trips are already
anticipated to be trips that would be
done by alternative modes of transport
in any event
no weight should be given to this factor
overall mr blair's eight factors do not
go nearly far enough to avoid the
modelled severe residual cumulative
impact on the local highway network
the majority are either uncertain
unquantified already taken into account
in the model results or overlap with one
another a number of the factors fall
into a number of these categories
ultimately the mppf entrusts the
judgment on whether a particular impact
is severe or not to the local highway
authority and now sir to you
notwithstanding the fact that ecc has no
objection the highways evidence before
this inquiry still needs to be
considered very carefully
the judgment of the highway and foreign
is not infallible mr blair has set out
in his evidence mistakes and adjustments
they did not spot
it's open to you sir to depart from the
conclusions of the highway authority
provided of course that their views are
taken into account and given appropriate
weight
and you do not need any new evidence to
do so
ecc has not given evidence and it's not
possible to test the approach that
they've taken
similarly the fact that the site is
allocated does not mean that the
residual cumulative impact cannot be
severe
as neither the core strategy examination
or the site allocations plan examination
in neither the core strategy
examination nor the site allocations
plan examination was there the level of
detail that's been explored at this
inquiry
that detailed junction modelling that
has now been explored for the first time
does show a severe residual cumulative
impact contrary to paragraph 111 of the
mppf
in terms of the overall planning balance
usa will no doubt take into account the
evidence given by all of the council's
witnesses
however the ultimate judgment on where
the planning balance lies in this case
is for you not for any one witness
as set out in the original reason for
refusal the council's position is that
the development does not result so it
does result in a severe residual
cumulative impact on the highway network
and should be refused for that reason
okay thank you very much mr parkinson
we've almost reached half past three are
people wanting a short afternoon mid
afternoon break before i hear from
the appellants so i'm flexible but i'm
going to be about an hour
about an hour so it'd be helpful if we
have a
15-minute break i think now so
yes yeah
well we'll just we'll have just short of
15 let's go to 3 40. so i'll adjourn now
we'll resume again at 3 40. thank you
hello
um
so
yeah yeah
well the inquiry is resumed ladies and
gentlemen
miss reed can i hear the closing
submissions for the opponents please
just ask them to be handed up sir
thank you
so i don't know whether it's appropriate
to mention we were a bit disappointed we
carefully
tailored our response to the
um
the time limit that was set for us
and i think mr parkinson was rushing
through his to
stay within the time limit as well so i
gave i gave an initial estimate of 45
minutes to an hour yeah i i commented
back to the parties i think in terms of
the
[Music]
closing submissions and i said what the
estimates i'd been given were and
certainly
miss reed's estimate of an hour is
within the range that she gave so
sorry we were advised 30 to 40 minutes
i said
i said in the case uh management
conference summary note ideally 30 to 40
minutes
and then when the estimates came in
i had i think rule six party said we'll
endeavor to stick within the the
guidelines uh mr parkinson estimated an
hour clearly he was less than that um
and miss reed said 45 minutes to an hour
depending on the the evidence that's
presented so
i i have no issues with
how things have been
presented to me so far thank you thank
you sir
so this is an appeal against the refusal
of an application for 662 dwellings
community building and associated
infrastructure on land east of ashington
road and north of rochester garden way
232 of the proposed dwellings will be
affordable homes
there was a single reason for refusal in
respect of the appeal scheme in summary
this was that the development would
result in a severe impact on the local
highway network
the council has been unable to
substantiate that reason for refusal
this was a scheme that was recommended
for approval twice by the council senior
professional officer in extensive
detailed and fully reasoned reports
following extensive engagement including
a public exhibition seven
pre-application meetings a plan and
performance agreement
the professional officer was plainly
right to so advise
indeed the headline point from the
evidence before the inquiry is that
councillor shaw who gave the evidence on
behalf of the local planning authority
expressly accepted that based on all of
the evidence before the inquiry planning
permission should
be granted
this was because it was accepted that
the proposal is in accordance with the
development plan
the tilted balance applies as a result
of the failure of the local planning
authority to demonstrate a five-year
deliverable housing land supply in
accordance with the minimum requirements
of the framework
um and um that the
um has your section missing
uh in accordance with the minimum
requirements of the framework
um and that the adverse impacts of the
scheme do not significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits of
the scheme when assessed against the
provisions of the framework as a whole
planning permission should therefore be
granted in accordance with the
development plan in the framework and
those are all points
expressly
conceded
by the council's own witness
it is also noted that councillor shaw's
concession that planning permission
should be granted was based on the local
planning authority's assessment of the
highway impacts of the scheme in the
planning balance
that is
even if the local planning authority is
right as to the highway impacts of the
scheme which it is not
on the evidence it is agreed that
planning permission should be granted
so i'm afraid i'm now going to have to
pause to make a comment sir
in respect of the way that the local
planning authority has put its closing
submissions
it is extraordinary
it is extraordinary indeed
that not once
in its closing submissions
has the submissions on behalf of the
authority recognized
that this was the evidence
given
by its own
witness
the chair of the planning committee
that is an unjustifiable
and significant and unreasonable
omission
from a closing submission
made on behalf of the local planning
authority
who have a public duty to assist the
inquiry
as to their assessment
of the planning balance
residents are perfectly entitled to come
and express a concern
that they have
in respect of an impact of a scheme in
their locality
it is the public duty of the local
planning authority
assisting the inquiry
to carry out the planning balance
in accordance with the statutory
development plan
and weighing all material considerations
in the planning balance
not a single
reference to the concession
made by councillor shaw in evidence that
planning permissions should be granted
in the closing submissions delivered on
behalf of the local planning authority
not a single
not a single
recognition
of the planning balance
and the material considerations
that weigh in favor
both in favor
and against the scheme
taking into account the statutory
development plan
and the provisions of national policy
and frankly it is not in those
circumstances a proper submission that
is now made on behalf of the local
planning authority
that permission should be refused
when there is not a single reference to
that planning balance
in the closing submissions
and not a shred of evidence produced by
the local planning authority to
substantiate an assertion
that taking everything into account
permission should be refused
on the evidence sir returning to the
closing submissions the points raised by
the local planning authority in respect
of highway impacts
on its own evidence take it precisely
nowhere
nevertheless the local planning
authority's case in respect of highway
impacts is plainly overstated
as the appellant set out in opening the
chronology in respect of the
consideration of this matter
demonstrates clearly that the planning
impacts of development would be
acceptable the inspector is referred to
paragraphs
i've paused you there you said you said
planning but i've got highways very
highways impacts yeah yeah okay would be
acceptable and so you referred to
paragraph six of the appellant's opening
which is not repeated here
in summary however this is a scheme that
has been rigorously assessed by multiple
professional experts on multiple
occasions
by the appellants transport consultants
through the ta and taa
by the appellant's expert witness
through his peer review of the scheme by
the highways authority by the local
planning authority's professional
planning officer on two occasions and
now by the professional witness
instructed by the council to defend its
appeal who has expressly agreed with the
appellant's assessment and in particular
that the residual cumulative impacts of
the scheme would not be severe
it is hard to conceive of a process of
consideration that could have been more
rigorous
how in the however in the end the
consensus of all the professionals
is that there would not be an
unacceptable impact on highway safety
and that the residual cumulative impacts
on the road network would not be severe
it is therefore clear on any basis that
planning permission should be granted
the proposed development is genuinely
plan lead it brings forward much needed
housing and affordable housing on a site
that the council has chosen to allocate
for development in its own development
plan
this is a policy compliant plan-led
beneficial development
the appellants are delivering
development in accordance with the
council's own strategy for growth on a
site that needs to come forward to meet
the critical housing and affordable
housing needs of this district this is
clearly a scheme for sustainable
development brought forward in
accordance with the development plan and
the framework
the agreement that exists following the
testing of evidence between the lpa or
at least the lpa's witness and the
appellant that planning permission
should be granted even if the lpa's
cases to highways accept impacts is
accepted is plainly a consideration of
the utmost weight in determination of
the appeal
in that context sir i turn to the main
issues that you identified at the outset
and the appellant submissions at least
will deal with all of them
main issue 1 planning matters including
the weight to be given to relevant
development plan policies
pursuant to section 38 6 of the act the
starting point is the development plan
the development plan is the council's
carefully considered plan that sets out
how the development needs of the
district are to be met framework 15
provides that the planning system should
be genuinely plan lead the proposed
development is genuinely plan led
because it brings forward much needed
housing and affordable housing on a site
that the council has chosen to allocate
for development in its own development
plan
extraordinary not a single reference to
that fact in my learned friends closing
submissions
this is a policy compliant plan led
beneficial development the appellants
are delivering development in accordance
with the council's own strategy for
growth
councillor shaw expressly accepted
that the policies of the council's plan
should be accorded full weight and that
the council did not rely on any material
considerations including increases in
traffic on the highway network to
suggest that reduce reduced weight
should be accorded to those policies
it is therefore agreed that full and
very significant weight should be
accorded to the fact that the proposal
will bring forward much needed
development in accordance with the
allocation of the site in the
development plan extraordinary not a
single reference to that in the
council's closing submissions
it is acknowledged that there are
concerns within the local community as
to existing levels of traffic on the
highway network
however as councillor shaw accepted the
councillors caught the council's core
strategy was subject to extensive
community consultation and involvement
prior to adoption and the council took
into account views of communities across
the district in identifying the most
appropriate strategy to make sufficient
for provi sufficient provision for
housing that the district requires
this is a district that is very heavily
constrained by physical constraints
including land at risk of flooding
ecological constrained areas protected
for landscape value and extensive areas
of greenbelt as councillor shaw accepted
these designations limit the location
where new development can come forward
to meet the housing needs of the
district
traffic is also identified as an issue
across the district as a whole and was
plainly considered in the formulation of
the planned strategy
given the existence of those constraints
including those relating to traffic the
strategy of the plan is to direct
development to the most sustainable
settlements where alternatives to car
use are more viable
in this context the core strategy
identifies four settlement tiers with
the settlements in the highest tiers
being more developed subject to greater
housing demand and need and generally
more suitable to accommodate additional
housing for the reasons described above
rochford is grouped together with
ashington as one of three tier one
settlements that is it sits right at the
top of the council's settlement
hierarchy and is as councillor shaw
expressly accepted therefore one of the
more suitable locations to accommodate
the additional housing that the district
requires
as the core strategy expressly notes and
as expressly accepted by council ashore
the top-tier settlements are the most
suitable for growth because they are the
most sustainable locations for
development in the district with a range
of services and facilities and where
sustainable modes of transport public
transport walking and cycling can be
encouraged
contrary to the surprising
cross-examination of mr blair by mr
parkinson which seems to suggest without
evidential basis that this might not
work
delivering developments that will reduce
reliance on the private car by directing
growth to the most sustainable locations
and encouraging measures that encourage
a modal shift to ease congestions are
stated priorities of the development
plan
and are also measures that the
development plan anticipates will assist
in addressing the specific challenges
faced by the district
not only is the appeal site located in a
tier one settlement and therefore
identified as a sustainable location in
principle but it is also a matter of
express agreement between the appellant
local planning authority and highway
authority that the appeal site itself is
highly accessible by sustainable modes
of travel
that is whilst recognising that there
are issues in respect of traffic across
the district the core strategy expressly
seeks to mitigate the impact of
delivering necessary housing by
directing development to the most
sustainable tier one settlements
including rochefort and ashington where
there are most opportunities to
encourage that modal shift to more
sustainable modes and by seeking
contributions to encourage and
facilitate the same that approach is
entirely consistent with framework 105.
councillor shaw therefore accepted that
taking into account the constraints
within the district and the comparative
sustainability of the settlement across
the district to accommodate growth it is
entirely appropriate and consistent with
the spatial priorities of the plan
to direct growth to rochford ashington
and to the appeal site in particular
the provision of an adequate supply of
good quality housing in appropriate
locations is a priority of the
development plan
further the core strategy recognisers
and council assure accepted that the
need for affordable housing is acute
with it with housing need data
indicating that the need for housing is
focused primarily on the three tier one
settlements including rochford some 29
of the housing waiting list demand was
noted to be in rochford at the point of
adoption
the core strategy is clear that the only
way that this can be addressed is
through the delivery of market-led
schemes such as the appeal scheme
as well as directing grace to the tier 1
settlements because they are the most
sustainable for growth and because these
are the areas where the modal shift can
be encouraged the plan also seeks to
direct growth to the areas that are most
in need of additional housing
councillors sure accepted that this was
another reason why in accordance with
the spatial priorities of the plan it
was appropriate to direct growth to
rochford ashington and it is a
settlement that has been identified in
the plan as one of the areas of most
acute affordable housing need in the
district
the core strategy recognized and
accounted for the fact that meeting its
housing needs would have some residual
impacts on the physical and social
infrastructure and on local communities
the core strategy which as already set
out carefully consider the views of
communities across the district
is therefore a strategy of balanced
distribution that ensures
a fair and equal division of new
development across the district
again
a point expressly accepted by council
ashore
in accordance with the overall arching
strategy
the plan identifies the appeal site for
development post 2021
by extending the residential envelope of
the settlement to deliver approximately
500 units
it is clear that in identifying that a
significant quantum of growth could be
accommodated on the appeal side the
council was well aware of the
constraints on the local highway network
indeed the preferred options documents
that informed the selection of the
strategic approach in the core strategy
expressly noted a level of traffic on
ashington road and in particular
that the railway bridge at the eastern
end of hall road was a severe constraint
on traffic movements
in short the constraint in respect of
the ability to deliver physical works to
mitigate impacts at the hall road west
street junction were known
at the time the core strategy was
adopted
nevertheless the core strategy
identified the appeal site for
significant growth balancing any
inevitable impacts of the scheme against
the need to deliver the council's
housing requirement in one of the most
accessible and least constrained
locations in the district
policy h3 of the core strategy sets out
what infrastructure was required to be
delivered alongside the housing proposed
this is the infrastructure listed in
appendix h1
which a policy h3 expressly requires is
to be read in conjunction with policy
clt1
and so just pausing that that that is
important those words in conjunction
with because policy clt1
envisages
that
the mitigation
should be and improvements should be
delivered
through section 106 obligations
and
just to be clear
council of foster is with respect wrong
that the
scheme will not deliver
local capacity and infrastructure
improvements
in accordance with the policy
because i must say so i shouldn't be
referred to as council of foster
sorry um
because
because
sorry is is wrong let me just take a
step back that is wrong
that there will not be compliance with
that policy
because local capacity and
infrastructure improvements are
to be delivered
through the section 106 obligation
and i'll just turn on now to my
paragraph 33
it cannot sensibly ie the policy cannot
sensibly be interpreted
as referring to anything other than
infrastructure improvements and capacity
improvements
that it is possible to bring forward
through section 106 obligations
constraints on the ground mean that
physical improvements cannot be
undertaken within the highway
at the hall road west street junction
as set out these were constraints that
were known when the site was allocated
policy h3 which identifies the site for
significant growth
cannot sensibly be interpreted as
prohibiting planning permission being
granted in the absence of improvements
to a junction that are a physical
impossibility for the developer to bring
forward through the section 106
obligation
that would introduce an irreconcilable
conflict into the development plan
and is inconsistent with a pla
inconsistent with a plain reading of the
provisions of the development plan as a
whole as councillor shaw accepted
it follows that the proposal is in
accordance with policy t1 of the core
strategy and policy and policy dm 31 of
the development management plan
in accordance with the overarching
strategy of the plan policy t1 requires
development to be located and designed
in such a way as to reduce reliance on
the private car
it is a matter of agreement between the
witnesses of the lpa and the appellant
that there is compliance with that part
of the policy given the site's location
in a tier one settlement within an
allocation and in a location that is
agreed to be highly sustainable and
accessible in principle
policies t1 and dm 31 then look to
ensure this appropriate improvements are
carried out as agreed by mr pie croft
and councillor shaw in the context of an
allocated site that is plainly a
reference to the requirements of the
allocation policy itself
and compliance with that policy means
that understood in their proper context
that is in the planet context of the
plan as a whole there is also compliance
with policies t1 and dm31
further policy t1 expressly envisages
that bringing forward necessary
development will mean that some impact
on the highway network will be
inevitable
councillor shaw fairly and rightly
conceded that even if the councillor's
case was right as to the impact at the
whole road west street junction which is
disputed this does not bring the
proposal into conflict with the policies
of the development plan because on the
council's case those impacts cannot be
mitigated by developer contributions
through section 106 obligations they are
an inevitable impact of bringing the
site forward in accordance with the
allocation
as set out above such constraints were
known when the site was
allocated and any such residual impacts
are of the type envisaged by the policy
taking all of that into account on the
evidence it is therefore now a matter of
agreement between the local planning
authorities evidence and the appellants
that there is compliance with policy t1
and dm 31 extraordinary not a single
mention of that in the council's closing
submissions
following the testing of the evidence it
is also a matter of agreement that there
is compliance with policy ser 8 as well
extraordinary not a single mention of
that either in the council's closing
submissions
it is a minimum requirement of policy
ser 8 and the allocations plan that 500
units should come forward at the appeal
site the council has therefore always
accepted that the principle of
significant residential development at
the site is acceptable in accordance
with its own plan
further councillor shaw accepted that
the appeal scheme for 662 units was in
accordance with the allocation this was
because there is a policy requirement to
bring forward a minimum of 500 units
that is a minimum figure and not a
maximum paragraph 3.227 of scr8
indicates that it will be appropriate to
bring forward more than 500 units where
the council cannot demonstrate a
five-year housing land supply and the
additional number of dwellings on the
site is required to compensate um
that should be for a shortfall of
development within the location
identified in the core strategy
it is agreed that both criteria are met
here and therefore the development of
the site for 662 dwellings is in
accordance with the allocation in scr8
and it is also agreed that the policy
does not impose a constraint on the
number of units that can come forward
based on highway capacity
further councillor shaw has also agreed
that the proposal complies with all of
the requirements of ser 8 relating to
the provision of infrastructure
including those relating to highways and
air quality matters
in particular
access and egress is provided to
ashington road and the council is
satisfied there is no material conflict
with para 3.243
whilst residents have expressed concerns
in respect of the access to percycottis
road that access has been provided in
accordance with para 3.244 of policy
scr8
in particular as mr blair explained the
arrangement of rows on the appeal site
are such that it will not encourage
through routing between ashington road
and the drive percy cottage road
in any event the proposed access has
been subject to an independent road
safety audit and it has been
demonstrated to be acceptable the
highway authority confirmed that the
access to percy cotta's road is safe and
suitable and councillor shaw confirmed
that the lpa did not allege the country
there is this is therefore a secondary
access that comes forward in accordance
with the policy requirement as
councillor shaw agreed
public transport infrastructure
improvements and service enhancements
are provided through the section 106
obligation the potential for the bus to
be diverted onto the site is not
considered to be necessary or
appropriate by the lpa or highways
authority and it's therefore accepted
there is compliance with 3.245
pedestrian and cycle routes are provided
through the site and off-site
improvements and links are secured in
accordance with 3.246 and 7 and it is
further of note that these paragraphs
also underscore that a modal shift to
reduce the use of private vehicles and
encourage walking and cycling is and i
emphasize particularly important in this
location
mr blair's evidence to which i'll return
later is wholly in accordance with the
adopted development plan in this respect
air quality has also been appropriately
assessed to the satisfaction of the
environmental health officer and the
local planning authority as explained by
mr grubb the scope and methodology of
the air quality assessment undertaken
through the aqa and addendum were agreed
with the environmental health officer as
robust and fit for purpose
the aqa addendum explains that the
estimated background air pollution data
for nitrogen dioxide pm10 and pm 2.5 was
taken from the defra website and the
background pollutant concentration
levels are then modeled based on source
parameters meteorological parameters and
topographical factors to 2019 and 29
measured levels at the ambulance sutton
road and south street location sites are
used to validate the model
the aqa addendum records and the
planning statements of common ground
agrees that vehicle emissions that would
result from the proposed development
would be negligible at all relevant
receptors including the schools and the
nursery and that air quality pollutant
concentrations would remain well below
air quality objectives in relation
to all of those metrics
as mr grubb explained there can be a
high degree of confidence that the
assessments which have been carried out
in accordance with accepted guidance
produced by defra and agreed with the
council's own professional environmental
health officer
are robust it is therefore agreed by
council ashore that the lpa accepts that
there is compliance with ser 3.248
insofar as it relates to air quality and
does not consider that planning
permission should be refused on that
basis
there is also compliance it is agreed
with 3.24 and 3.244 of policy scr8
together these set out development must
provide appropriate highway improvements
and infrastructure to appropriately
mitigate the impacts of development the
list of requirements in the policy
mirrors that in policy h3 and council
assure therefore accepted that there is
compliance with these po these
paragraphs too for the same reasons
councilor shaw therefore accepted that
the proposal will be brought forward
wholly in accordance with policy scr 8
of the development plan and
taking all of the above into account
expressly accepted that it follows that
the proposal is wholly in accordance
with the development plan
extraordinary
extraordinary that the closing
submission offered on behalf of the
local planning authority
does not recognize that its own evidence
accepts
that the proposal is wholly in
accordance with the statutory
development plan
in short this is a scheme that is
genuinely plan lead that will deliver
growth in accordance with the council's
own strategy in a settlement right at
the top of the settlement hierarchy and
on a site allocated for development by
this council and will deliver the
mitigations and improvements envisaged
by the policies of the council's own
development plan
council ashore's evidence was that full
weight should be accorded to the
policies of the council's plan and very
significant ways should be attributed to
the fact that the appeals site complies
with it the appellant wholeheartedly
agrees
main issue two housing land supply not
only is the proposal in accordance with
the adopted plan but it is also a matter
of agreement between the local planning
authority
and the appellant that it is critical
that the site comes forward in
accordance with the plan to meet the
housing needs of the district
meeting the general and affordable
housing needs of the district is a key
priority of both the development plan
and national policy
however
the council's housing needs are agreed
to be acute and the council is failing
to deliver the homes that its residents
desperately need in accordance with the
stated priorities of its own development
plan and national policy
it has never been more important that
sites identified and allocated by the
council in its own development plan as
appropriate for growth in principle are
allowed to come forward to meet those
critical housing needs
since 2008 to nine there has been a
persistent and year-on-year failure to
meet even the constrained housing
requirements identified in the plan
the shortfall to date is 829 units
without the appeal site it is agreed
that the council cannot meet even its
constrained housing requirement to the
end of the plan period
even if delivery comes forward in
accordance with the council's trajectory
which it was agreed would be challenging
based on previous delivery it is agreed
that there will be a shortfall of some
331 units to the end of the plan period
it is agreed that the shortfall against
the adopted housing requirement
in light of that the delivery of housing
on this allocated site carries
significant weight
this is because without the appeal site
the council cannot deliver its planned
housing requirement to the end of the
plan period contrary to the key
priorities of its own development plan
however it is also agreed that the
council's housing requirement is
constrained and is out of date because
it does not reflect the requirements of
the framework which sets a higher local
housing need figure in accordance with
national policy the council's housing
need has increased to 362
dwellings per annum
there is therefore a need for additional
land to come forward but as a minimum it
is clearly imperative that sites that
have been allocated through the plan led
system come forward to meet identified
needs in a timely manner
the council cannot demonstrate a
five-year housing land supply in
accordance with the minimum requirements
of national policy it is agreed that the
council can only demonstrate a 4.04 year
supply and the shortfall which exceeds
the annual requirement for an entire
year is plainly significant the fact
that the council has recently passed the
housing delivery test does not assist it
because the 4.04 year supply is based on
a five percent buffer in any event
and irrespective of whether the council
passes the hdt
it remains national policy
that there is a requirement for the
council to demonstrate a minimum
five-year forward supply of housing land
the council cannot do so and that is a
plainly a significant material
consideration in favor of the grant of
permission
beyond the five-year period it is also
agreed that against the local housing
need figure of 362 dwellings per annum
there will be a shortfall of 901
dwellings to 2031 again plainly a very
significant shortfall
the appeal site can make a significant
and meaningful contribution to the
five-year supply
since it is a matter of agreement that
should the appeal be allowed the
shortfall in the council's five-year
housing land supply would be addressed
by deliverable dwellings on the appeal
site the council is right to agree in
the statement of common ground that
additional housing should be accorded
significant weight in the planning
balance in these circumstances
the provision of affordable the position
in respect of affordable housing is also
stark
this is an authority
where the affordability challenges have
increased since the adoption of the core
strategy
the plan is not delivering homes that
those most in need require
the figures are sobering the housing
register has grown by 20 percent in the
last year alone
to around 1 000 households
and the ratio between house prices and
local earnings is recognized by the
council
to be amongst the least affordable in
the country the least affordable in the
country
one thousand households on the housing
register and not a single mention of
that in the cloud council's closing
submission where it should be assessing
the planning balance
there has been a cumulative shortfall in
affordable housing delivery every single
year since the start of the plan period
in 2006
the cumulative shortfall in affordable
homes now stands at a whopping
1006
homes
further it is agreed that there are only
471 affordable homes in the five-year
housing land supply that will not begin
to scratch the surface
of addressing the shortfall of over 1600
homes let alone account for newly a
rising need indeed by the end of the
plan period the shortfall in affordable
housing need is expected to increase to
some 2325
dwellings
the situation is agreed to be acute and
the situation is agreed to be critical
and the pain council is plainly right to
agree in the statements of common ground
that the weight to be attributed to the
delivery of the significant quantum of
affordable homes that will be delivered
through this scheme is right at the top
of the scale the outlook is poor and the
position is sobering not least for those
1 000 households that are on the housing
register now and that have little
prospect of accessing a decent home the
scale of the problem and the impact of
it on real people in real need in this
authority cannot and should not be
underestimated
it has never been so important that
sites that have been allocated through
the councils the council's plan
are allowed to come forward in
accordance with it this scheme will
deliver 232 dwellings which is nearly 50
percent in one fell swoop of the council
council's existing supply of affordable
homes it will address the needs of real
people in real needs on a site that the
council has identified as appropriate
develop in its own development plan
the prospect of housing needs being met
otherwise are bleak as mr pycroft
memorably noted it was agreed that
one
there is insufficient capacity within
the allocations in the existing plan to
begin to address the council's critical
of housing and affordable housing needs
two as a result of greenbelt and other
constraints it is unlikely that
unplanned windfall developments will
begin to address those needs either
three there is no prospect of a new plan
coming to the rescue to address the
council's housing needs anytime soon the
appli the emerging plan is only at
regulation
18 stage
in any event councillor shaw agreed that
whatever option is pursued through the
emerging plan the council accepts that
the appeal site will need to come
forward to meet the council's housing
needs going forward this is because as
the council's own strategic options
document which has been approved by the
council's policy committee and full
council accepts the council will need to
make best use of its existing planned
developments in every single one of the
potential options that might be
progressed through the plan in
accordance with the minimum requirement
of national policy to meet its housing
need assessed through the standard
methodology
councillor shaw accepted that this
expressly includes maximizing the
development potential of existing
allocations including the appeal site
that position has been reached in full
knowledge of the traffic constraints
that the council says exist across the
district and which are also taken into
account in the document and which the
council would have been aware of before
voting to approve it
councillor shaw therefore correctly
accepted that whatever option is pursued
through the emerging plan it is clear
that the site will be required to meet
the council's housing needs going
forward
taking all of the above into account
council assure expressly accepted that
it is critical that the appeals site is
released now to meet the housing
council's housing needs the appellant
agrees it has never been more important
that the council's allocated sites come
forward in accordance with its
development plan to meet those acute and
critical needs otherwise the position
will indeed remain bleak for the many
residents who will be deprived of a home
that was planned to be delivered through
the council's own development plan
maina issue 3 highways
the council's evidence started here
in its statement of case with an
allegation the scheme was unacceptable
in highway terms for six reasons
the council's evidence has ended up with
an acceptance that four of its reasons
relating to highway safety and parking
are completely resolved and in fact
councillor shaw now accepts that there
will be net benefits in respect of
highway safety and parking a point to
which i'll return later
further as to the points raised in
respect of highway capacity and
congestion the council's evidence
started with general concerns raised as
to the impacts on highways across the
study area the council's evidence has
ended up with being confined to an
impact on a single arm of a single
junction during part of the am peak in
circumstances where the expert appointed
to defend the appeal on behalf of the
council agrees that the residual
cumulative impacts on the highway
network will not be severe
further to the extent that this impact
will occur it is accepted to be the
inevitable consequence of bringing
forward the allocation in accordance
with the council's plan and in
circumstances where the constraints that
preclude works within the highway at
that junction were known when the site
was allocated
for the reasons that i'll set out the
council's remaining limited case is
overstated but even taken at its highest
it it cannot justify the refusal of
permission in these circumstances
as council assure expressly accepted
nevertheless turning to highways issues
that have been discussed at the inquiry
highway capacity the highway authority
is the statutory council t
the highway authority has concluded
following careful consideration
that the residual cumulative impacts on
the highway network would not be severe
its position has been confirmed in a
highway state
statement of common ground and in emails
to mr blair's evidence
there is an obligation for the decision
maker to have regard to its consultation
response as a material consideration and
it is also a well-established principle
that great or considerable weight should
be attributed to the view of the
statutory council t
and where the lpa departs from it there
must be cogent and compelling reasons
for doing so
there are no clear and compelling
reasons to justify a departure from the
considered opinion of the highways
authority
council eve's evidence does not come
close to meeting that evidential
threshold
the local planning authority's case now
appears to rest on the argument that the
appeals scheme will cause cues at the
hall road west street junction back to
the dallas road junction this was not
raised in the local planning authority's
statement of case proofs rebuttals or
examination in chief and it appears to
be based on a single comment made
following the break in cross-examination
from councillor eves that he was
concerned about queuing back to that
junction
if this was genuinely a concern of the
local planning authority one would have
expected to see at least a mention of it
somewhere in evidence there was quite
literally none the comment was
unsupported by evidence and is
unsupportable
the professional consensus between the
authors of the ta and taa the
appellant's professional witness the
highway authority the council's
professional planning officer and the
expert appointed to defend the case on
behalf of the local planning authority
is that the residual cumulative impacts
on the highway network will not be
severe that is plainly the right
approach and the professional consensus
is plainly a matter of the most
significant weight in the planning
balance
the highway authority has scrutinized
the appellant's assessment and this is
agreed to be appropriate by the highway
authority
it has also been scrutinized by the
expert instructed by the lpa who agrees
that it is appropriate subject to
revised agreed position between the
parties in respect of additional
junction mitigation at junction 3.
the final paragraph of the highway
statements of common ground confirms
there are no outstanding issues between
the experts
residents and council eves are concerned
about the existing level of traffic on
the network however councillor eves
accepted that the baseline traffic flows
were accounted for in the assessments of
the ta and taa and that he did not have
any evidence to challenge the traffic
survey
further he expressly accepted that the
traffic survey used in the model was
representative of traffic conditions
the traffic survey is plainly reliable
it was undertaken pre-pandemic outside
of school holiday periods and midweek on
a thursday which residents say is
particularly problematic because it's
been collection day
further the results in the traffic
survey are consistent with those
observed by mr blair on his site visit
finally the highways authority has also
compared the traffic survey data against
the data that it holds and has confirmed
that it is appropriately representative
as mr blair explained there are all six
photos which are not time-stamped and do
not quantify traffic or explain whether
conditions are atypical and the rule six
video which appears to show moving
traffic that periodically platoons and
possibly waiting at road works is not a
robust basis for challenging the agreed
survey data that has been benchmarked
and agreed by the highways authority
the ringway jacobs report produced by
the rule six party does not take the
debate any further either it is a report
that was published in 2017 on behalf of
the highways authority its conclusions
record that its purpose was to inform
the cons inform the consideration of the
local plan and help define the scope of
transport options for proposed
applications the highway authority have
agreed the scope of the assessments
carried out by the appellants and
mitigations proposed in full awareness
of the content of the report
indeed as already set out the highway
authority has already expressly advised
that it has validated the appellant's
traffic survey data against data that it
holds and has confirmed it is
representative and appropriate
second the report expressly states that
it is to inform the emerging local plan
as we have seen the council's emerging
strategic options document which post
dates the ringway jacobs report
continues to recognize that it is
necessary and appropriate to bring
forward and in fact maximize development
on the appeal site notwithstanding its
recognition that there are traffic
issues across the district finally for
the avoidance of doubt and contrary to
the position of the rule sixth party the
appellants consider that the scr-8
allocation has been considered in that
report but in any event with respect it
is unclear where all of that takes the
rule six party because the key point is
that the highway authority are plainly
aware of the circumstances on the local
highway network
and have agreed
that the appellant's assessments are
appropriate and robust taking into
account their local knowledge and data
the expert opinion of the highway
authority is that the residual
cumulative impacts on the highway
network post mitigation will not be
severe
on undertaking his peer review of the ta
and taa
mr blair checked and validated
the models used as he explained his
revised model results are clearly the
most appropriate models used to use to
understand the impacts of the scheme
and i just pause there to note paragraph
18
of mr parkinson's closing submissions
which
appear to suggest that the position
might be otherwise
and note that those comments are not
supported by evidence
because the local planning authority's
evidence on this point is contained in
the first housing statement of common
ground
where it is agreed by mr flexman on
behalf of the local planning authority
that mr blair's validated models form an
appropriate basis
to carry out the assessments
and so returning to the text
the reason that these are the most
appropriate models to use to understand
the impacts of the scheme is because
firstly the models have been updated to
reflect changes to the geometry on the
ground which is plainly appropriate
secondly the models have been adjusted
to ensure the appeal site is not double
counted in the assumed growth it should
previously be included as part of the
baseline because temporal growth rates
include allocated sites and thirdly the
trip rates used are more representative
and appropriate for example saturdays
have now been excluded selected
pre-covered data and excluded non
non-representative sites based on the
census from the tricks selection
parameters used
councillor eaves confirmed that he did
not challenge any of the inputs into the
model and the highways statement of
common ground one with the local
planning authority expressed the agrees
the updating of trip rates growth rates
and validating of base models set out in
mr blair's evidence
in response to points raised by the mp
as to the number of trips that might be
generated by the development simply
multiplying the number of car parking
spaces to derive an assumed number of
trips for the site is plainly not a
robust approach
as mr blair explained
mr blair's assessment has used tricks to
calculate trip rates which is the
industry recognized national database of
surveys and methodology there has been
no challenge to parameters used to
select the most appropriate sites
traffic counts in the ta were undertaken
on a 15-minute basis and trip rates were
combined with the 15-minute peak periods
to find the worst case accounting for
local peaks again that approach is
plainly robust and has been agreed by
both the highways authority and mr
flexman and was unchallenged by
councillor eaves
the rule sixth party has noted a concern
that the combined impacts of allocations
ser t2 and scr8 has not been considered
that is wrong because scr-2 was
accounted for in the temporal growth
rates applied in the model it's an
allocated site and scr8 is the appeal
site that was the subject of the
assessment
further the analogy drawn by the rule
six party with the reign and kent appeal
decision as misconceived
because there the local planning
authority and dependent disagreed as to
which model more accurately reflected
traffic conditions
on the network
in this appeal there is only one model
before the inquiry and that is the
appellants and there is no disagreement
with either the highway authority or the
local planning authority that it is
appropriate for assessment purposes and
so i just add in that here a couple of
additional non-highways points in
response to in response to the rule six
closing submission um the raynham kent
decision can also be distinguished as mr
pycroft
explained
on the basis firstly that that was not
an allocated site
that was being brought forward in
accordance with the development plan
and where traffic impacts were
sorry traffic constraints were
known at the time of allocation
and secondly
that there were additional significant
material considerations
that weighed against that proposal in
the planning balance
not least the significant landscape
and bmv
issues that are recorded in that
decision
so significantly different appeal
on all of the facts
and not relevant
to the determination of this appeal
for the reasons set out by mr pycroft in
his evidence
returning to highways framework 111
provides that the scheme should only be
refused on highways grounds if the
residual cumulative impacts are severe
as councillor eves accepted what this
requires is an assessment of traffic
impact post development
and includes an assessment of the
effectiveness of the proposed
mitigations
neither the rule 6 party nor the lpa
have produced any evidence let alone
clear and compelling evidence to justify
departure from the opinion of the
statutory council t
that the mitigation will be effective
and that the residual impacts will not
be severe
to the contrary mr flexman and council
eves accept that in 2029 with the
development in place
in respect of junction 2 site access
operates within capacity in respect of
junction 5 amberlynn showed to be
capable of working within capacity and
betterment post development with only a
minor improvement scheme although the
obligation in the 106 also allows the
contribution to be made to a future
highway authority scheme to deliver more
comprehensive improvements
in respect to junction 3
um which is the ashington road roach
avenue dallas road junction the year
2029 model shows betterment of over 15
and an alternative mitigation approach
shows a 4 betterment and in both cases
the junction will operate within
capacity and in respect of junction road
which is ashington road rectory road the
position is now agreed with the lpa and
subject to the agreed mitigation scheme
again shows betterment post-development
with mitigation and the model shows it
to operate within capacity
for the avoidance of doubt councilor
eve's concern that the mitigation at
rectory road might not be safe or
suitable because quote we have been here
before
is wholly without evidential foundation
or merit
counselor eve's rebuttal indicates that
the highway authority's previous concern
related to the way in which drivers
approached and undercut that junction
and the previous location of the
roundabout was a key contributor to that
however the previous alignment was in
fact different to that proposed here
there was not a formalised two-lane
approach and the roundabout was in a
different position
the proposed and different alignment of
the proposed litigation scheme has been
the subject of an independent road
safety audit and is considered by the
highway authority to be safe deliverable
and effective and mr flexman does not
raise a highway safety point in respect
of this either
with respect council reeves does not
have a scrap of evidence to support his
point and it is unsurprising that
councillor sure accepted that there are
not clear and compelling reasons to
depart from the opinion of the highway
authority that the proposed mitigation
at rectory road is safe and effective in
short following physical highways
mitigations and safe for the point that
the lpa now raise in respective junction
4 all junctions are improved with
development and mitigation as compared
to the base position
it is surprising that this is not
something that is welcomed by members
and residents given their concerns in
respect of existing traffic conditions
indeed as mr blair explained the level
of improvement in performance is in fact
likely to be greater because these
models of results do not take account of
the non-highway work mitigations
proposed either
i now turn to the only remaining
substantive point between the local
authority and the appellant junction 4.
in respect of junction 4 councillor
reeves expressly confirmed that his
concern as to a severe impact only
related to the iem peak
whilst there would be an impact on
junction performance in time segments
other than between 8 a.m and 8 15 he did
not seek to rely on any time period
other than the impact in that time
segment 8 o'clock to 8 15 to demonstrate
that there would be a severe impact on
junction 4.
his evidence in respect of severe impact
was therefore effectively limited to the
impact at the ashington road arm of a
single junction in a 15-minute period of
the am peak the local planning
authority's cross-examination of mr
blair which has sought to extend the
point well beyond the point raised by
councillors is completely devoid of
evidential foundation
in any case the points raised in
cross-examination of mr blair albeit not
in evidence as to the single impact on a
single arm of a single junction during
part of the am peak are plainly
overstated
the worst case in respect to this
junction is set out in mr blair's
evidence the model shows an exceedance
of capacity with additional cueing and
delay however it is agreed between the
professional experts that where junction
models forecast exceedances the result
is exaggerated and the model is likely
to forecast queuing and delay that is
worse than will occur
the total demand in pcus with
development is only 25 pcus higher than
without development in the time segment
that was a segment that was of concern
to councillor eaves that is only 25 pcus
would need to be removed from the
network to achieve nil detriment in this
time segment
only six pcus would need to be removed
to achieve the same impact that would be
inevitable from implementing a 500 unit
scheme which is the minimum requirement
of the council's own allocation policy
although none of this is to be found in
any of the council's evidence in
cross-examination it was put to mr blair
that queues would start building bats at
dallas road at junction at some point in
the previous segment to
7 45 to 8 a.m that would not be the
effect price of 7.45
aside from removing 25 pcus in 15
minutes to achieve full mitigation and
in any case an ill detriment is not
required by framework111
mr parkinson postulated that if the
whole hour is taken into account only 46
pcus would need to be removed from the
southbound ashingdon roadflow to achieve
a position
where the robustly forecast queue would
not stretch back to the dallas road
junction
to put that figure in context 46 pcus is
only 4.8 of the 987 junction arrivals
across the hour
there are eight reasons why the worst
case
uh modeled impacts are unlikely to occur
one peak spreading there is no dispute
between the local authority and the
appellant on the evidence as to the
potential for peak spreading whereby
motorists avoid the busiest peak period
to significantly reduce the modeled
impacts this is because based on his
local knowledge and mrs wright's survey
councillor eves the council's witness
expressly accepted that peak spreading
has in his words a significant potential
to remove traffic from the network in
this location there was no challenge by
councillor eve to mrs wright's survey in
fact in re-examination he expressly
accepted it and in his words recorded it
high weight
further based on mrs wright's survey
council reeves agreed that it was
reasonable to assume that around 10 of
people could change their travel time to
avoid rush hour in the am peak as mr
blair confirmed that alone could bring
numbers down by around 90 in the hour
against mr parkinson's target of
removing 46 pcus indeed this point alone
goes 90 percent of the way to achieving
full mitigation 25 pce's in each quarter
which would achieve nil detriment
trip diversion the simple point put by
mr blair was that if a southbound
vehicle saw a queue ahead at the dallas
road roundabout it could turn left to
avoid the queue if its destination laid
to the east or the south
approximately two-thirds of traffic
turns left from ashington road at the
hall road roundabout so it's likely that
two out of three cars approaching that
roundabout could undertake such a
diversion the simple point is that
southbound drivers would not slavishly
add to the queue where there is a
preferable alternative route and
consequently the forecast q length is an
over estimate and will not occur in
practice
the study area
as explained by mr blair the model
assumes that all trips will travel
through
the
junction in the study area that means
that all trips are to be modelled as
impacting um on the study area junctions
in reality that assumption is overly
robust as some trips will have a local
destination eg in the town centre and so
will not be present right across the
study area again notwithstanding mr
parkinson's efforts in cross-examination
there is no dispute between the parties
in respect of these points because
councillor eves expressly accepted that
trip diversion has the potential to
reduce the modelled impact at junction
4. mrs wright's survey also supports
that conclusion with 61.7
of respondents indicating they sometimes
change their route to avoid ashington
and 1.29 at 1.92
indicating that they could do so again
in the future and again
perhaps a paragraph 43 of the council's
closing submission
which seeks to which urges you to give
no or limited weight to these matters
is expressly contrary to the evidence
given by the council's own witness
counselor eves
who expressly accepted
that trip diversion
had the potential
to reduce the modelled impact at
junction 4.
returning to the text in short it is
agreed that peak spreading and trip
diversion have a significant potential
to reduce the modeled impacts at
junction 4 as explained by mr blair and
this is an approach that has been
accepted by other inspectors
schools
where schools are proposed as part of a
scheme captioning not
available no new schools are proposed
within the site but there are five
schools in close proximity and walking
distance of the site
twelve percent of car trips in the am
peak are associated with education and
it's therefore reasonable to assume
there'll be a reduction in trip
generation from the site by virtue of
the good walking links and very close
proximity of the schools
working from home and internet shopping
the trend is clearly towards more
flexible working from home and internet
shopping council eves considers and this
is his answer to my learner's friend in
re-examination that and i quote this
will be the norm by 2029 and further
that changes to working patterns allow
people to quote do errands in cars at
different times his words the parties
therefore agree that these factors have
a significant potential to reduce trips
temporal growth the model accounts for
allocated development in its growth
factor but does not take into account
the mitigation and improvements that are
required to be delivered through those
schemes again this means that in reality
trips will be fewer than modeled there
was no substantive challenge to mr blair
in terms of those points in
cross-examination
travel plan the travel ban targets a 10
reduction in trip rates it is robust and
effective that capitalizes on the highly
sustainable location of the site and
proposed in sustainability improvements
whilst it is right that the trick sites
used to quantify trip rates will have
included a travel plan mr blair's point
was that the travel plan here is
particularly robust and beneficial and
founded on the good locational
accessibility and sustainable
infrastructure that the development
delivers it is the case that the travel
plan will be successful and that um and
um that there will therefore be a
reduction in trips purely by way of
example the normal requirements of the
highway authority is that residents will
be offered a six-day bus pass the scheme
will deliver a choice of a three-month
bus pass or 150 pounds cycle voucher as
part of a travel plan to incentivize
transition to sustainable transport
whilst providing the choice to residents
highway the highway authority agree and
they have commented that this is a
comprehensive travel plan that will in
their words further reduce reliance on
the private car
in short the travel plan here is
particularly beneficial it's like to
have likely to have been beneficial
effects beyond those who are account
accounted for in the base data and
agreed by the highways authority and
again councillor eves expressly accepted
the point that the travel plan had the
potential to reduce trips from those
accounted for in the model and should
therefore there should therefore be no
dispute on the evidence in respect of
this points contrary to my learner's
friends paragraph 37 which again
is inconsistent with the evidence of his
own witness
sustainability enhancements the section
106 obligation secures significant
contributions
and a number of significant
sustainability enhancements
these include the upgrading of bus stops
real-time information bus service
enhancements pedestrian and cycle links
across the appeal site opening up
alternative routes to king edmonds
school and waterman primary diverting
pedestrians and cyclists off washington
road and removing pedestrians and
cyclists from the halt farm schools
cycle infrastructure upgrades identified
in the rochford cycling plan flagship
routes one and two and connecting the
site with the town centre and employment
sites
the highway authority expressly comment
that these enhancements are suitable
mitigation to address the whole road
west street traffic impacts of the
development
that approach is plainly consistent with
mppf 105 which expressly sets out that
the planning system should actively
manage patterns of growth and that
significant developments should be
focused on locations that are or can be
made sustainable through limiting the
need to travel and offering a genuine
choice of transport modes
the framework then expressly recognizes
that such measures can reduce congestion
and that approach is also reflected in
the council's own development plan
policies where measures to reduce
reliance on the private car are
encouraged for that very reason
again council reeves accepted that the
sustainable location of the site
together with the proposed sustainable
transport contributions has a
significant potential to reduce car
journeys and there should be no sensible
dispute about that point
taking all of the above into account on
the agreed evidence there is a
significant potential to reduce trips
this will reduce the traffic impacts of
the scheme from that which has been
modeled the robust modelling did not
take any of the eight reasons into
account
councillor eve's remaining point
appeared to be that he didn't know by
how much
that misses the point
first the appellant has never been asked
to carry out any additional work to
quantify the same and none of the points
that were put to mr blair in
cross-examination have any evidential
basis whatsoever have been regarded the
council's statement of case proof and
rebuttals
secondly the highway authority has
expressly confirmed that they agree that
the residual cumulative impacts of the
scheme would not be severe and that the
sustainability measures provide adequate
mitigation at the hall street junction
the highway authority's initial response
related to the modeled impacts in the
taa mr blair's verified agreed model in
fact gives a 22
improvement as compared to the ace model
that was initially considered and the
highway authority confirmed to
demonstrate an acceptable impact but in
any case the highway authority has
further confirmed that
it is also key to reaffirm that the
application must be viewed holistically
and appreciate the package of network
improvement measures to facilitate modal
shift from part of the
form part of the highway authority
acceptance of the scheme considering
those points the position of the highway
authority remains unchanged and the
proposed development does not constitute
a severe impact
as set out in opening it is well
established that great or considerable
weight should be attributed to the
highway authority's conclusions and
where the lpa departs from them there
must be cogent and compelling reasons
for doing so it is not there for the
appellant to produce evidence to prove
that the highway authority is right
because for the lpa for the first time
in cross-examination tries to discredit
the points that have hitherto being
accepted by all parties if the council
wish to demonstrate the highway
authority is wrong it is for the council
to produce clear and compelling evidence
to substantiate its point and of an
evidence perception that the agreed
mitigations might not be quite as
effective as all of the professionals
agree they will does not come close to
even reaching that evidential threshold
that is particularly the case since
councillor eve's own evidence accepted
that a number of mr blair's points did
in fact have the potential to have a
significant impact on the worst-case
traffic impacts
taking all of that into account the
council's reason for refusal that there
would be a severe impact at junction 4
is unsupported by evidence
but in any event the council's reason
for refusal does not properly affect
reflect the test in framework 11 which
is where there will be a severe
residual cumulative impact on the no
road network
as well as overstating the impact at
junction 4 without a scrap of technical
evidence to justify it the council has
not carried out a full assessment of the
residual impacts on the network it has
not considered that any impact would be
for a limited period within the am peak
only and it is not considered that there
will be further improvements and a
beneficial impact across other junctions
in the study area which is now accepted
in evidence
in short it is plain that the residual
cumulative impacts of the scheme would
not be severe there is professional
consensus between the appellants the
highways authority and the local
authority's own professional highways
consultants as to that point
highway safety
the proposed highway works including
off-site improvements new site accesses
and road frontage arrangements have been
the subject of an independent rsa and
subsequent designers response no
untypical or unacceptable issues have
been raised and the local authority
accepts that the proposal would be
acceptable in highway safety terms
as councillor shaw confirms having taken
advice from the professional consultant
the local planning authority now accepts
that
this is because whilst the footwear and
cycleway will be narrowed at 3.25 to
4.51 metres it will still exceed the
highway authority standards and will be
wider than the remainder of the
pedestrian cycleway route that exists on
this part of the route the width of the
shared cycle route is not only in
accordance with the highway authority
standards but also in accordance with
ltn 120 having regards to the fact that
through movement is slow as explained by
mr blair pedestrian and cycle surveys
time-lapse videos and photos also
demonstrates that there are limited
number of commuter cyclists that use
this route particularly at the peak
school times when pedestrian movements
are higher cyclists need to slow it the
two can crossing to cross to the other
side and will not be travelling at speed
and in any event the pedestrian and
cycle surveys have demonstrated
that pedestrian and cyclists can still
be accommodated safely within the
proposed footway
all accepted now by the local planning
authority on the advice of its
professional consultant
further as accepted by council ashore
the scheme will in fact deliver net
highway safety benefits
including flashing leds school ahead
warning signs upgrades the visibility of
the pedestrian guard rail and 20 meter
extension
of it
anti-skid surfacing on the road and a
refuge island that will prevent
overtaking the vicinity of the school
and contribute to reducing traffic
speeds
councillor shaw and mr pycroft agree
significant weight should be attributed
to those benefits
funding has been provided so the school
can bring forward amenity enhancements
and on-site facilities to drop off and
pick up which were particularly welcomed
by councillor shaw the parking issues
raised by the rules six party and
members have also been resolved because
ten dedicated spaces for school drop off
and pick up will be provided with the
community facility this is now agreed by
councillor shaw to be an enhancement
over the existing situation
in that it will provide dedicated spaces
where currently there are none and a net
increase in the number of spaces
available council assure agreed
significant weight should be attributed
to that benefit
taking all of the above into account the
agreed position between the local
planning authority and the appellant is
now there for that a there are no
highway safety reasons that justify the
refusal of planning permission and b to
the country the highway safety and other
highway benefits of the proposal should
be accorded significant positive weight
in the planning balance
main issue 4 planning conditions and
obligations
other concerns of the parties have been
considered in the appellant's planning
proof the conclusions of which are not
repeated here but so we refer you to the
appellant's planning proof for its
evidence in respect of those points and
i'll give you the reference there
it is nevertheless of note that there is
no objection from any statutory council
t and it's agreed by the council that
all of the development impacts can be
accommodated in this case subject to the
agreed conditions and section 106
obligation that have been agreed with
the local planning authority and county
council as discussed at the inquiry
those include contributions to education
libraries healthcare youth facilities
and rams
main issue five the planning balance
there is agreement between the parties
that the scheme will deliver a package
of significant benefits to existing and
proposed residents alike including
highway safety benefits significant
package of highway improvements and a
particularly robust and effective travel
plan these benefits have been discussed
and it is agreed should be accorded
significant positive weight in the
planning balance community building and
land offered first the nhs for a pound
or alternatively to the council through
the mechanism in the section 106 with a
further contribution to the nhs
dedicated school parking facilities also
provided as part of the facilities
agreed that significant positive weight
should be attributed to this benefit in
the planning balance
flood alleviation and drainage works as
well as mitigating the impact of the
scheme those will also deliver off-site
improvements by improving drainage and
therefore reducing flood risk at nearby
properties the unchallenged evidence of
mr pycroft was that these should be
accorded moderate weight in the planning
balance public open space and recreation
space benefiting existing and proposed
residents alike the unchallenged way to
evidence of mr pycroft was that these
should be accorded significant weight in
the planning balance economic benefits
for the reasons given by mr pycroft
those should be according to moderate
weight in the planning balance this is
clearly a high quality beneficial
development scheme but in any event the
critical point is this
this high quality plan led scheme will
positively deliver against the council's
own strategy for growth in accordance
with the policies of the development
plan in a settlement at the top of the
hierarchy on a site this is being
allocated for development it is a scheme
that the council needs to come forward
now to address what are accepted to be
at least by
the chair of the planning committee
the critical housing needs of the
district in accordance with its own
development plan
the consequences are significant if the
site is not permitted to come forward in
those circumstances the council will not
be able to meet even its constrained
housing requirements the end of the plan
period the council will not be in a
position to recover its five-year
housing land supply in accordance with
the minimum requirements of national
policy and the opportunity to deliver
232 affordable homes on an allocated
site in a district that faces some of
the worst affordability constraints
nationally and where there are some 1
000 households on the waiting list and a
shortfall of over 1600 affordable homes
to date will be lost
the council's remaining case in respect
of cumulative impacts on the highway
network is overstated it is without
evidential foundation all of the experts
agree there would not be a
severe residual impact on the highway
network and permissions should not be
refused in accordance to with framework
1-1-1 but in any case even taking the
council's case at its highest councillor
shaw accepted that any residual impacts
arise as a result of physical
constraints that were known when the
plan was adopted the principle of
development here has been established
through the allocation of the site and
the plan led system refusing planning
permission because there will be
inevitable impacts on the highway that
cannot be mitigated in circumstances
where the council has taken the decision
to allocate the site in full knowledge
of the constraints that exist is the
antithesis
of the plan led system
it is unsurprising having been taken to
the compelling evidence in favor of the
scheme that councillor shaw who gave the
evidence on behalf of the authority that
lpa
ultimately accepted that not only should
planning permission be granted but that
it is critical that this site comes
forward now
in accordance with the policies of the
council's own plan to meet the council's
housing need the lpa's evidence now
records that accords with that of the
professional officer of the council who
twice advised in the strongest possible
terms it would not be reasonable to
refuse permission for the proposed
development the agreement of the local
planning authority that permission
should be granted for the scheme on the
evidence should plainly be accorded very
significant weight in the planning
balance
in conclusion therefore this is a
beneficial plan led scheme for
sustainable development brought forward
in accordance with an allocation in the
development plan that will deliver a
package of the benefits including much
needed housing and affordable housing in
a district where there is an acute and
critical need to deliver the same the
tilted balance applies and the adverse
impacts do not come close to
significantly and demonstrably
outweighing the benefits of the scheme
when assessed against the provisions of
the framework as a whole the lpa has
agreed in evidence that planning
permissions should be granted and it is
respectfully requested that the appeal
is allowed and permission is granted
without further delay in accordance with
the statutory development plan and in
accordance with the framework so those
conclude my submissions unless you have
any further questions and so just for
your note on the back sheet right at the
beginning of the inquiry you asked me
who i was instructed by and i've just
recorded that in in writing at the back
there
okay thank you very much
so i have the 106 obligation here when
you're ready as well yeah that's not
that's the first on my list of uh last
points to go through can it be handed up
then please have you good
okay thank you
sir
sir
i'd like just like to say some
misread took one hour 18 minutes and i
know we've been over this before
but we've stuck to our time and had we
known we could have had longer we would
have brought more into it but we're a
little naive we don't know we stick to
the rules well with with due respect mrs
austin you didn't stick to your time in
that you you you had if you want to put
it that way
at least 40 minutes and you were well
less than that but
it it is what it is it's
you you need to be able to put forward
the case that you want to put forward i
don't want to have any more debate on
this as i say the the appellant has the
final say on this what i've seen today
is by no means
untypical of public inquiries so please
let me just move on deal with the final
points here thank you okay
so the next the next one on my list is
actually um
the
attendance list for today so
is it is there anyone present who hasn't
yet signed it was a few hands up so can
we
do that again please
and before i
move to close the inquiry can i just
check does anyone have any final
application to make
no
thank you
in that case then it does just remain um
for me to thank all participants for the
helpful way that you've
conducted yourselves throughout these
proceedings
and the inquiry is now closed thank you
so i've just been asked sorry sir i've
just been asked by those that instruct
me as well to um
pass on our thanks to the camp to the
council officers for assisting us with
the organisation and and so on
you